[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III 2018 stage I'm Mike McCarty here
with Lucy James hey and I'm really
excited for this one it'll be our last
interview for the day
we are gonna talking to John block who's
been working diligently on Metro Exodus
since I you came to our stage last year
I believe yeah yeah then what was it
announced was it what was announced last
year Yeah right show it off at the
Microsoft stage this year yeah so tell
us like Metro last light is one of my
favorite games I wholeheartedly think
it's one of the best shooters ever made
it's a fantastic game I mean I love 2033
as well but last night I think is just
phenomenal I'm really excited for Exodus
that I had to get my fanboying out of
the way by what is uh what are some big
like with some of the biggest new
changes with Exodus that we can expect
on early next year
well so we're on the biggest change when
the biggest changes it's a dish inria
Lee is these new sandbox environments
right open world style environments that
we've added to the game and we showed a
little bit of that last year but this
year we're really diving in and and
showing off kind of like what it means
to play in an open kind of in a more
open environment in the Metro universe
previous Metro games as you know have
been more linear a lot more focused on
kind of crafted experiences they carry
the player through you know a deep
narrative and in Exodus we really wanted
to expand on that end and give players a
lot more freedom and a lot more ability
to explore the environments you know
even this level that we're showing right
now there's many hours of gameplay just
in the critical path and there's many
many more hours of gameplay inside
content that that we've added to kind of
give players more of what they of what
they love about that show so from a
design point of view for you guys
obviously the two games you've been very
focused on this linear path what's it
been like for you to open up and go to a
more open setting it it's taken a lot of
kind of experimenting I think it took us
about two years to really land on a
formula that we liked that blended the
two kind of design ideas this is this
new idea that we wanted to do
you know leveraging past experience of
some of the team members that had worked
on stocker back in it back in the day
and and kind of blending it with this
established linear story driven game
play that the fans of the Metro series
have kind of come to know and love in it
it took us a while to get there but
we've kind of come up with this new way
of doing things that's a little bit
unique to us it's not like a traditional
open world style game where it's all
fetch quests and you know going around
there it's like doing menial tasks for
people we wanted the game to feel a lot
more natural in in how side content is
exposed to players how they find it we
want players to really immerse
themselves in the environment and really
feel like they're actually there right
so narrative Lee from I understand you
are travelling across Russia yes that
sounds pretty ambitious compared to like
the first game you were pretty much all
almost always in the Metro last flight
you went above ground a little more it
wasn't as it radiated if I'm not
mistaken or maybe it was just like you
were above ground more in the medigun
different places right right it was all
it was all within Moscow exactly yeah so
but now you're kind of going the breadth
of Russia yeah speak yeah but that way
the journey in Metro Exodus takes place
over the course of a year and it spans
the continent you go so many different
places and it kind of gives us an
opportunity to explore for ourselves and
for our fans new environments you know
new landscapes and because it takes
place over the course of the year new
seasons in this environment that that
we're showing off today is our spring
environment it takes place just south of
Moscow and the Volga region off the
Volga River okay and it's this big you
know expansive environment next to a
river it's kind of swampy you see the
snow is starting to melt there's
possibly weather systems like
thunderstorms in in in this area and all
of these things kind of come together to
really you know show off great new new
places that the player can can can go to
so like how will I beat when I jump into
Exodus you're saying like that you're
you're creating these more like open
ended areas like how when I'm playing
the game will it be more like I'll
explore this area for a few hours like
what will be the impetus to do that I
mean obviously exploration is rewarding
in its own but will that also lead into
like craft
has always been big will that be in like
a survival aspects be kind of feeding
into the exploration as well yeah so
another new feature that we're
introducing this time is we're kind of
changing the economy system in the game
before we had bullets as economy you get
these military-grade rounds that you
could put in your gun for extra power or
you could spend them like money so you
have to kind of you know think about the
balance of that before you approach the
situation now that's that system worked
for the society in the Moscow Metro
system it works because they had
established it as their currency but
leaving Moscow it's the wilderness you
don't really know what's out there
there's not necessarily gonna be some
organized group of people that are
living and you know the same way that
people in Moscow are so it's more of
like a scavenging crafting and resource
management system so there's like metal
bits and chemicals things like that that
you can find that that when put together
you can make things like med packs gas
masks filter is the the things that you
need you can also craft ammunition and
so exploration is in in in Metro
actually this is really important from a
standpoint of you know players want to
explore and see what's in there and you
get a lot of fiction delivery that way
but also there's there's resources that
the player needs in order to survive in
order to you know go and go and attack a
compound so you're gonna need you're
gonna need things in order to survive
right
we've also overhauled the weapon system
now you know in in in past metro games
the weapons were customizable but more
in a preset way yeah good upgrade and
get a get like a premade upgraded
version of that weapon now we've
completely redesigned the weapon system
from the ground up it's more modular
there's five hard points on every weapon
and you can swap out anything from a
barrel to stock magazines you know
adding attachments scopes lasers things
like that I saw in the gameplay can you
just do it directly from your backpack
yeah so that all the time there's two
different places that you can do this
then there's there's workbenches around
around the
environment and you can do a whole lot
more you can craft everything that you
possibly need you can customize your
your gear and your weapons you can craft
any of the ammunition you need you can
also clean your weapons which is a new
thing that you need to do and exodus you
got to maintain them right otherwise
they'll when they get dirty they'll
break down a lot more they'll overheat a
lot more and generally a performance of
the weapon will will reduce when they
get dirty so you need to maintain them
out in the field at any time you can use
your backpack to do most of the same
things you can you know change the the
loadout of the weapon to kind of modify
any of the attachments or any of the
parts to you know say your you're gonna
go into a building and you want to be a
bit more stealthy you can swap out for a
silencer and maybe you know red dot
sight something for close-quarters
stealth combat and then you know if
you're gonna go approach another
facility from a distance you can then
attach you know something like a long
barrel and a two times you know 4 times
sight on on your weapon so it gives
players the ability to change things on
the fly yeah kind of adapt to their own
desired play style but also maybe
something is necessary to change you
know in the moment just returns back to
exploration for a moment like if we're
exploring these brand-new areas as their
chance that we can return to them later
you kind of have to get all your stuff
out of the way before you move on so
Metro Exodus is still gonna be overall a
linear kind of progression yeah there's
still there's a story that the player
works their way through and as you as
you make it through certain areas you're
gonna continue on I mean even you know
within the story the idea is is to
continue on and and to see what's out
there so it's it's still gonna be more
of a linear story arc whether it be a
beginning a middle and an end like like
a story should have so the first the
prior two games obviously like
especially last light emphasized stealth
using shadows and everything and with
the gameplay we just saw looked like
it's you're pushing that again are you
still trying to go for that maybe not
binaries right word but you can either
go stealthy or loud with the new
survival aspects of the game do you feel
as if it's pushing more towards stealth
or is it still just as much of a choice
for how you want to play it I think it's
just as much a choice
as before even areas that that may be
situationally seem more more apt to
stealth style approach if you fail
stealth the game transitions into fully
you know loud combat scenario they eyes
been overhauled in a lot of ways Humana
and and Krrish AI particularly in these
large environments it's more of like a
biome system where they have these areas
that they'll hang out in and and and
they live in they patrol and they sleep
they eat if any outside influence comes
in they will react accordingly whether
that be other AI or whether that be the
player as well human AI has has had a
big overhaul this time around so it's a
lot more communicative to the player in
the sense of the player can understand a
lot more of what they're doing they talk
a lot more amongst themselves and and
react a lot more naturally even possibly
surrendering if the player has taken out
enough of their their friends and they
kind of like realize well maybe I should
give up it's funny to see so many games
it seems like survival is a big trend in
games and I mean like fallout 76 is
emphasizing a lot and then you look at
like last light and 2033 you are doing
it for a while already but it seems like
you're going all out into survival with
Exodus is that like you see that as like
maybe like a central tenet of this game
I feel like it always has been to some
extent yeah we're definitely pushing it
a little bit more in this one with the
we have the opportunity with these open
environments to to really push that a
lot more because the player this time
around gets to kind of set their own
pace you know in previous matches
because everything was so crafted and
linear as developers we kind of set that
pace like the story kind of sets that
pace for everyone but this time around
the the player even though there's
there's still that narrative thread
carrying you through and and giving you
your main objectives there's still a lot
more opportunity for the player to kind
of experience it as they want to these
side quests missions gonna be feeding it
back into that main critical path or
they're kind of like it's they're kind
of like standalone little bits of
content that you can that you can
experience within the same environment
so that narrative thread will always be
there calling you back to it and pushing
you along the side content is kind of
there in ways that are gonna feel a lot
more natural to players to find the more
organic so metro 2033 I think like a lot
of to see it as a cult classic Metro
last light still like much more exposure
and like any time people say they like
shooters I say like if you love shooters
we should play last light if you like
half-life 2 you should play last light I
again it's one of my favorite shooters
but what's it like to have the exposure
of being on the Microsoft stage what two
years in a row now like it's clearly
you're on a much bigger scale there's
much more recognition what's that like
it's been really exciting I mean it's
it's something that I think some extend
it feels like it's the that you know a
long time coming kind of a feeling you
know that I feel like we've always been
a little bit of like an underdog team
where we've done things very similarly
through these three projects as far as
like the amount of passion and an energy
that that the team puts in so to really
you know making these games the way that
we want to make them and I think that
it's it's really nice it's really
humbling and it's and it's really
awesome to to see so many people kind of
getting behind that and agreeing with us
that that that you know they like what
we're doing as well so it's been the fan
feedback been like from the new trailer
so far it seems really positive people
are getting really excited and and and
it's really exciting for us to see that
too like we've we've tried really hard
this time around as well to to really
take fan feedback into account from
previous games definitely things you
know like I was talking about with the
AI systems a lot of the overhaul came
from fan feedback adding these open
spaces that it's also come from fan
feedback fans have been asking for this
sort of thing for a long time we've
always wanted to do it and and you know
we finally get the chance to do it this
time I think I think everyone's gonna be
really happy with it so earlier in the
day we had dying light too and the
people from tech land come up here and
then we had CD Projekt RED cyberpunk
2077 now we have you guys and
it's I've been saying and I've been
wanting to lie I love talking to
developers from like that Eastern
European scene because it seems like
it's just like this burgeoning like
development scene what's it like to be a
part of that it's really cool I mean
it's a especially coming from the
Western world it's a corner of the world
that isn't really well known to us
especially in you know a sense of like
media that is created and in in in the
region and I think it's really cool to
see a lot of really awesome games come
out it come out of the area and really
showcase the immense amount of talent
that is coming out of Eastern Europe you
know especially in recent years well
John block as the executive producer on
Metro exists or anything that we didn't
touch on that you want to tell people
where do we cover it I mean I think we
covered a lot of the main points except
for the release date yes we announced in
the trailer that we debuted on the
Microsoft stages here
it's Metro Exodus is coming February
22nd 2019 on Xbox one Playstation 4 and
PC awesome I'm looking forward to it as
always John block thank you so much for
coming up on our stage awesome thanks
for have a great rest of the week and if
you're watching from home we have a
bunch of videos that we have recorded
already that we are going to be rolling
as soon as this is over so don't go
anywhere and then later on today we'll
be back onto stage you know we'll have a
bunch of our partners with GameSpot
coming up in chasity pasensya will be
taking over but right now here a bunch
of IDEO as you can watch the pastime and
catch up on e3 news see you around